you
oh of course they talked about it
incessantly that was the main subject of
conversation for many years and so
people had very strong feelings about it
on both sides and people who thought it
was the greatest thing that ever done
and people who thought it was just an
unpleasant job and people thought they
should never have done it at all so the
opinions of all kinds
well it's very hard to tell I mean it I
I grew up in England at the time when
England was winning Nobel prizes right
and left I mean it was amazing how many
Nobel prizes England was winning in
chemistry and physics and biology and
all the sciences and at that time the
teaching of science and the schools was
really lousy I mean I I experienced that
myself we learned almost nothing in
school science was very unpopular it was
I mean science was blamed for all the
horrors of World War one just as it's
blamed today for nuclear weapons and and
quite rightly I mean World War one was a
horrible war and it was mostly the fault
of science so that was in a way a very
bad time for science but on the other
hand we were winning all these Nobel
prizes well since then of course
teaching of science in schools in
England has improved tremendously and
the number of Nobel prizes has gone down
and I think that might even be connected
I don't know but it's I think it's quite
possible that the more science you teach
kids in school the more it turns them
off so I don't know I mean you never can
tell which way it'll go
indeed there are of course I mean it
it's it's strange in a way that we had
already we were scared of biological
warfare in the 30s our endeavors Aldous
Huxley wrote his novel brave new world
and started out with anthrax bombs so we
knew all about anthrax already in the
30s and in fact we expected that I mean
World War one when World War two came
along which was when it when I was a
teenager we all expected we would have
anthrax bombs and this kind of stuff we
thought it would be a biological war
fortunately it wasn't and and but it's
because the danger is still there and
forth by the some miracle we did we
escaped all that and so you never can
tell what's going to happen but biology
certain there could be even worse than
physics and chemistry
of course exists there have been on a
small scale there have been and of
course a few people got killed with
anthrax right here in Princeton
well it's always a mixture we don't know
with some things to a better than you
expected other things go worse so I'm I
think the only sensible thing is just to
wait and see and the what I'm doing when
I'm writing books I'm not doing science
so much anymore mostly I'm just writing
books for the public and so I trying to
just describe for the public what the
choices are what they might have to have
to expect in the future and so by
warning people ahead of time maybe you
have an effect I think the fact that
Aldous Huxley wrote brave new world and
talked about anthrax bombs probably
helped because it meant at least we
people had the understanding before the
war began that's something we didn't
want to get into so I think it's much
better to have your eyes open but on the
other hand of course it can do harm if
you tell people look there's all these
terrible things you can do and then some
idiot may go ahead and do it